so Dan we know that you love sports and
let's say you had five minutes to sit
down with a short filmmaker before they
make their short film and you're their
coach what are you gonna coach them on
what do you know say to them they
haven't made it yet maybe they're ready
to go they might have a script yeah I
think the biggest thing is is it's going
back to its belief belief on what you're
the story you're trying to tell belief
in the subject matter you know and I say
that in the sense of you you can't
anything you do whether it's this
festival if you are in sports if you you
know our say you're a basketball coach
and but you don't love basketball how
are you going to put that passion energy
into actually doing it well and being
succeeding you can't you're not you're
going to fail you will lose you will
fail same with a story or a film you
want to get together and make a film
with a group of people and you have to
rally up grips DP their crew pas
assistants to follow you in help in any
way you need actors to say okay I want
to emotionally give to you and I'm not
ready to do this because you don't seem
that interested or that vested in this
or you don't believe in the story or you
don't know anything about the story so
that's why I go back to also when I said
earlier like you have to tell a story
you know like tell the story you know
that you can tell you could make don't
like try to do something you're not
that's not familiar to you just because
you think oh it's Daniel said this is
what you have to do this how you get in
festival you make it this way or some
festival programmers said yeah but if
you film us to be great and inherently
good anyway it doesn't matter about
genre or style whatever is also the film
is just be good and a good film comes
from someone who believes and their
story is passionate about the story they
make any film that's won our Festival
and won awards they're not films that
were just made with like little blase
effort this is not happening
these films were dedication our spam
money lost and you know a belief in the
story also understanding the story that
trying to tell because they have a grasp
on it they're really passionate about
what they wrote many times the
filmmakers in the short space are a lot
of times not every time of course not
but a lot of times it is a writer
director you know that's the same person
right so if you wrote the script you
know the material you should know well
if you didn't write it then you believe
in it strongly that you say hey I want
to team up with you and I want to make
this film and I can director your
writing I can direct your story you know
but you have to have that that passion
and belief because you don't have that
you're just going to fail the film won't
be good there will be areas where it
will falter
people will know that you know they're
not you're not someone to follow because
if you're directing a people the same
way you're managing someone or coaching
or all those areas if if you're talking
to your the players and they know you're
talking out of your ass and you don't
believe what you're saying
and you're giving a half-ass effort they
know what they sense it and not gonna
fight for you they're not gonna play
hard for you they're not going to care
same way as in crew and actors if you
want someone to give you their all as an
actor especially with the actors they're
passionate they trying to give
themselves to you whether it's emotional
stuff whether it's a break down scene or
you know it's a fight scene and it's a
couple arguing and they're you know
they're having a real issue time they're
married couple in the movie they're two
actors are not married they're actors
they have to you have to believe that
they're there that there's a married
couple in there fighting and they got to
get it out of you got to get it out of
them and how do you do that if they
don't like you at all or they don't
believe in what you're trying to do or
how you're trying to direct them or the
story you're trying to tell or just how
you operate like if you don't really
they don't feel your belief in passion
for what the story is and the movie
being made they're just gonna give a
half-ass effort and it's not gonna be
good and or they gonna want to get out
of there and just knock the lines out
and go home you're like you know I'm
done with this project I don't care this
is not for me this is not good enough
for me or whatever whatever and just get
it over with so that I think that's a
big thing it's really and it sounds
simple and obvious but it's not always
the case
a lot of people might do a lot of things
half-assed I don't believe what they're
doing or or I think they do but don't
really or they in this case when it
comes to storytelling maybe they just
want to try to impress and make a story
that's not their own or not something
that they believe in because they don't
know the material well enough or they
don't understand the nature of what
they're trying to tell with that story
then a problem showing you know it'll
see whether it's even a writing flower
if it is a story about went back to now
G of sports right what if it's a
basketball story in and it makes no
sense in in terms of a basketball
setting like the writers understand bass
well does like basketball but they want
to make a basketball movie because
someone told them do it or something and
it's gonna show that they don't know
what the heck they're talking about the
story won't make sense now as a viewer
or Washington whether you're like oh
you're watching a scene of a basketball
game and the score makes no sense and
it's not really making any sense to what
an actual supporting it would be like
right like if you know like it wouldn't
make sense then all of a sudden you're
like this is stupid this is a bad movie
and they don't understand the story
they're trying to tell they don't know
the sport like you know if you're using
analogies for baseball they're meant for
basketball like things like that like
keep me in the basketball
and the sports sports sense of the
sports realm so yeah you know really
knowing and loving what you're trying to
do with the project is that first and
foremost is critical
it's the must and you'll see reflect and
I go back to the winners because if
you're winning the festival our festival
others be nominated for Oscars those
films aren't made you know with with
like a lack of passion or effort or
belief in the story none of those
filmmakers have made those stories have
gone that far made these films you know
just on some casual whim let's just make
this thing uh you know shoot a one day
knock it out and just cram and who cares
about detail okay it's not that it's
made with dedication passion time
passion time and effort all those things
not to mention of course talent other
things you have to have that so that's
something the biggest thing
you